It's time for hatred.
Mail, a lot of focus, a lot of reaction to
my segment last week in my Hispanic am I Latino?
Am I just a white guy? Uh, and this week's
Patriot focuses on that.
But first, a quick reminder, what is hatred
male.
Anyway
[inaudible]
because if you aren't prolife you deserve
the death penalty.
Hey Trey, it may be written by patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and because
freedom
like with many a week's this week's hatred
mail needs no more introduction than to say
that a lot of people, uh, beyond me saying
that a lot of people were extremely triggered
by learning that.
Yes, I am an immigrant to the United States
from Latin America.
Take a listen to this.
David, you are a Hispanic Latino's just accepted
yet another great reason why you should never
have been allowed in.
I know you want to be white, but sadly for
you.
No, no, no.
You can speak Spanish as much as you want
but no can do here.
You will never be American.
I am Hispanic.
Latinos and speaking Spanish is something
that we really need to be looking into very,
very much more.
Um, I don't really have much more to say about
it.
I think it really speaks for itself.
The only thing I will remind you of is that
the best way to height, to fight hatred, autism
in your own community is to use the coupon
code hatred 40 when you become a member on
our website, join pacman.com the coupon code
hatred 40 saves you 40% you get 100% of the
member benefits and it's a big double middle
finger to the hatred, nuts, which we just
love and and encouraged.
So please sign up@joinpacman.com apply the
coupon code hatred at 40 do the right thing,
a fight, hatred prism in your local community.